the jurogan experience
what do you think
of this this the raid
was that
justified
um
well
i'll caveat this by saying it's it's
speculation because i you know i haven't
seen the affidavit no i you know not
many people have so
um
but then i'll start by saying
it's yet another
uh self-inflicted wound by trump
right he didn't need to
end up like that he
the departure from the white house was
fairly chaotic as you can imagine right
that's just the nature of what they were
doing they
you know there wasn't it wasn't the
level of of uh organization it wasn't a
very buttoned up administration right
and it was in part because they had a
lot of churn and and personnel and all
this but
you know you can you can argue that
every administration has some back and
forth with the national archives over
what is and isn't presidential record
what they can keep as their own personal
material and what has to be the
government like what's the what would be
a reason well i mean if it's if they
consider it personal correspondence or
they consider it um you know information
that that um
you know
is not uh classified and and is just
material that you know one day can end
up in a presidential library or they can
use to write a book when they finish up
and they want to you know make a few
hundred million dollars on a book then
fine
but there's always typically some back
and forth that goes on about okay what
is and what what what isn't and what can
we get but you know that requires a
process right and that requires you know
there's this protocols involved for
saying what you can what you can take
with you right and but you can
and so if they had done that if they'd
done the right thing
they wouldn't have ended up in this
situation and what they did was they
once again you know trump is able to
like suck all the oxygen out of the room
right and
and it's just it's one of those things
that i think was just unnecessary was it
was it was the raid
justified uh i don't know because i
don't know what
what the specific documents were that
they're really had at jones about they
were been negotiating this for some time
right they'd been talking to them and
going back and forth and they discussed
what you know what they had and how is
it stored and all the rest of it and
they'd gotten 15 or so boxes earlier
um
why they didn't just do that all in one
you know effort and say okay we need we
have more documents maybe it was taken
the archives a while to understand what
was and wasn't in the materials that
were returned or was
so i
i don't know i just you have suspicions
that it was a political maneuver uh it
was that the design was to
cast more
bad light on trump and
eliminate him from the 2024 elections or
well try to figure out a way to diminish
his appeal yeah i mean i think that's
there were there politics in the sense
that um you know a lot of you know folks
up on capitol hill or took delight in it
right and and found it to be you know uh
a really good piece of entertainment but
if you say politics from the the fbi's
perspective um from the department of
justice's perspective
um
i mean i know a number of of guys that
work for the bureau and i know them to
be
really solid people they're just they're
street guys they're investigators they
do their job they're very very good i
don't know anybody senior in the doj or
at the bureau so i don't know
how politicized they are and whether
that played into it or not
but
i you know people that are actually
engaged in the in the search you know
that show up
uh
at mar-a-lago they're doing their job
right and they've been told this is what
we have to do
you know
i think that it was such an
extraordinary step
and so unprecedented
that
um
you know maybe i'll be proven wrong once
they release the affidavit and we all
find out what was what was sitting there
but i can't open think that they they
had a reason why they said no we can't
we can't just keep dragging along here
because we're not getting the responses
we need so we do need to go in we need
to knock on the door and say look we
gotta you know now
i i do suspect that they could have
approached it differently you know and
not had the presence they had and
everything but
um who knows again it's this is the
problem we live in in this world today
there's immediately after that took
place there were people on the left and
people on the right who were absolutely
sure they had exactly the information to
make a decision about what this meant
and and why it was done or why you know
why it shouldn't have been done
and that's part of our problem you know
you know the unsatisfying answer is you
got to wait and find out what exactly
occurred to see whether it was justified
or not but nobody wants to hear that
right it's like after a terrorism
incident everybody wants an answer
immediately right well it's an
investigation and those things take time
you know all i can say is the folks i
know at the bureau are really quality
people but
do people at the top of an organization
are they more politicized well sure
there's a tendency for that to happen
right because that's you know they've
been around a long time they're at that
at that position because you know they
work closely with you know politicos or
whatever but
yeah it doesn't really answer your
question i've just spent a lot of time
talking in circles but well it's just
it's all it's so confusing for someone
like me that's like going well what is
what's going on here is this all is
there more than meets the eye or is this
like clearly an example of him doing
something that is 100 forbidden but he
feels like he can do it because he's
donald trump and he feels like the rules
don't apply to him i mean that's the
that's what the fear is right yeah yeah
well i think i think he's he's certainly
always pushed the envelope i don't think
it's any it nobody can really argue the
fact that he's kind of used his own
playbook right all along and
and you know you can't just say and then
people he's he's saying things like well
i declassified the documents you know
they're all declassified well you can't
just click your heels and say these
documents are declassified right there's
a process that takes place otherwise
it's a complete [ __ ] goat robe right
nobody knows what's classified what's
not you know you can't just in your
presidential head say okay i'm
declassifying everything related to
you know whatever this was does a
president have the ability to declassify
things sure unilaterally yeah
unilaterally so he could declassify
documents and then conceivably store
these documents yeah but there's a
process for that right i mean did he not
go through the process
based on what has been reported so far
but again without the affidavit without
the specific details who knows but if
there's documentation that's not
cataloged and marked as declassified
right that's again that you know it has
to show that if you've got a document
that's you know top secret you know code
word
and
you look at it and it's marked top
secret you know um
code word then
[Music]
you know you have to assume it's still
classified right and there's a mere fact
of him saying oh no you know
last year i declassified that it's that
doesn't hold water you can't
you know he has to follow protocol and
that's where i think he slips up is he
doesn't necessarily believe that applies
to him or he's just not you know it's
just not the nature of he's not
compliant yeah so and then he's isn't he
suing now to get documents back yeah he
is and also to have
information not um not released i
i think
part of this problem again it kind of
goes back to what we're talking about
before with the transparency of the us
government
when they
talked about this in this whole
conference room in doj wherever they
talked about it and they said uh you
know we're thinking about
conducting a raid and the bureau doesn't
like to use the word raid or doj doesn't
like to use word raid but when they say
we're
talking about doing a raid on the
on the
home of the former president
they probably should once again from a
messaging perspective step back and
thought to themselves okay what is what
does that mean
how are we going to justify this
not that they have to but they should
have known how
what a firestorm it was going to create
and so they should have had that
completely buttoned up and ready to go
the moment they were going to do it and
be as transparent within the limitations
of what they can do
of
what they were doing and why they were
doing it
be because if they don't they create all
that open space right and that's where
everyone jumps in and starts declaring
what exactly happened without knowing
what the [ __ ] happened right and then
you get all this misinformation and
disinformation and and it's another
[ __ ] you know goat rope so
it's it you know it's a it's a process
that i think you know they the attorney
general probably should have uh handled
better because he had to authorize it
they also had to go in if the white
house says they didn't know anything
about it
that's where i'm going to call [ __ ]
at the white house saying we had no idea
that the ag was authorized to search the
president's former president's home
yeah
probably that's not the case they're
going to have you hey you have to assume
they got to walk in sit down and say sir
we got
a little something we got to talk to you
about and just let you know this is
coming down the pike yeah so how does
that play out you think
you think that is it nothing is it all
much ado about nothing and will not
impact him or will it be a significant
factor yeah i think i'm gonna lose that
thousand dollars to you because i think
it's i think he's gonna run again i
don't think it's gonna stop him from
from running um
i think they'll uh
they'll realize this
you know the the the hard left is saying
oh he's got you know the world's most
dangerous secrets held at mar-a-lago
right and the right is saying
you know he declassified it all there's
nothing there and the truth is like it
typically is somewhere probably in the
middle and in the middle they're
probably going to realize they don't
have anything to indict them on i could
do it's going to be like all these other
things that they were kind of going
after
and
yeah um so i'll be cutting you a check
if you take a chance i could venmo you
or paypal yeah yeah we'll do that yeah i
do those things nowadays
yes so for someone like me who's on the
outside just trying to pay attention to
as little as i can
and still talk about it
it's very confusing
yeah it is uh it's odd it's [ __ ] odd
um if you think about it i mean we could
end up with biden and trump running
again in 2024. i don't think biden's
gonna run i don't think it's possible i
think he's so deteriorated i think he's
gotten to this point where you know
we're only two years in and he's already
completely fallen apart where he can't
form sentences anymore i can't imagine
they're going to look at him as a viable
candidate in 2024 i mean a large
percentage of the democrats don't want
him to run yeah that seems to be the
case for sure
and no one's excited about kamal harris
they got that lady tucked away somewhere
god i i don't know what she's doing i
really don't know what a job is anymore
but um but you're right
the problem is he's gonna have to make
that call right so he's got to make that
decision to say i'm not running in 2024.
therefore he clears the decks and then
you get this mad scramble of a couple
dozen people chasing him because i think
you're right in in in previous times
they would have deferred to the vp right
i don't think they're going to do that
yeah they're not going to they're not
going to do that so you're going to have
this this uh
this free for all um where you get
people like gavin newsom pete boudej
uh probably bernie sanders again
and yeah i think he's even older than
biden i know but he's entertaining um
and uh you get you're just gonna get a
host of characters coming in
uh because i don't think they're going
to say fine we'll clear the decks for
for harris so i agree with you 100 on
that one but um
it doesn't look good yeah it does well
there's no like real like exciting
options 330 plus million people i forget
what the population of the u.s is
nowadays but 330 plus million people and
these are the options we get nobody
wants to do that job it's a terrible job
well plus you also get the primaries and
they vote for the hard edge you know so
you get that person who says i'm all for
you know clean energy yeah climate
change is the number one problem vote
for me and then you get the people on
the far right that say i'm all about
banning abortion and contraception and
porn and so the hard right you know
maybe the conservatives on the hard
right vote for them and that's what
happens in the primaries
unfortunately because you get the
registered people that are
voting and you get that self selection
that just [ __ ] us over